a Victory lap for Mexico's
president all aboard the Maya train a
1500 kilm Railway designed to connect
some of the country's best known tourist
destinations the construction ran
billions of dollars over budget face
multiple lawsuits and fierce criticism
from
environmentalists still 5 years after
first breaking ground the ambitious
project is a reality as president Andres
Manuel Lopez sador or amlo inaugurated
the first three of the Network's seven
lines the entire circuit should be
completed by March
no we are not exaggerating when we say
there is currently no construction
project in the world like this one and
it was done in record time these Works
generally span over several
governments neither of the criticisms
nor the delayed train bothered these
passengers thrilled to be on its
inaugural trip they believe the
president's promise that the train will
lift southern Mexico out of poverty
bringing jobs tourism and development to
a long neglected region the service is
excellent the train is in very good
condition some things need to be fixed
but the train is
great but the train has also brought
destruction thousands of hectars of
jungle were cut down to make way for the
tracks and directly below is the
Region's unique network of underwater
Cades activists fear they could be
contaminated by the train or Worse still
could collapse entirely amlo sees the
Maya train as part of a larger plan to
modernize Mexico from new airports to a
coast to coast cargo line intended to
rival the Panama Canal before his
critics the whole thing is just a
vehicle for his ego for his political
ambition being pushed through before the
end of his
term after all the hype the communities
that live along the path of the train
hope that despite the ecological and
economic costs in means brighter days
for them ahead Julia gallano Al jazer
Mexico
City make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jaaz